i'm here to introduce the girls in
gaming fireside chat Lina Chen is the
CEO and founder of nyx Hydra games Lina
welcome she just walked in i was texting
her where are you she is trumbull 2008
one of my best friends and started this
amazing company it's a mobile gaming
company that's very popular with young
women they raised series a back in 2014
with Foundry Group leading their round
their hit game is called egg baby and
they have over 15 million downloads and
to my understanding they got there with
very little formal marketing or
advertising so it's really been like a
massive success and she's going to be
interviewed by Tyler he Tyler is a
gaming enthusiast and investor he's
currently at tencent games where he
works on business development and
investments and he is Yale 2012 seabrook
so come on up well thanks for joining us
today Lina thanks for having me yeah so
I guess it's a it's best to start with
you know story of Nick's Hydra how did
you and your co-founder get started and
how did you see this opportunity for you
know mobile games for women yes so um
well we were both were both Ellie's
actually and we met at Yale we were
boasting trumbull and then after
graduation we moved out to LA where
we're roommates and we were just it was
actually we didn't have any experience
in the gaming or tech or startup
industry I worked at William Morris
which is a talent agency and TV and she
worked perfectly she works of a [ __ ]
imma at the time which was making um
like animation at a video game Angeles
so it was like a little bit in there but
barely any experience because this is us
just starting out and we were just
looking on our phones to be like what
can we play and we couldn't find a lot
of stuff that we wanted to play or loved
and so we're like oh look who's making
these the stuff so I started going to
tech conferences at it was and
especially gaming conferences i like
very very male-dominated you're like
okay well like it's kind of it makes
sense why they don't understand us
sometimes so we're just like okay we'll
make these games that we want to play
and there's a whole large market out
there people just like us other young
women who want to play things on their
smartphones or who would if there were
cool things and that's how we got
started we did not know how hard it was
going to be or was just like oh yeah
we'll just make a game but it was it was
rough in the beginning so tell me a bit
more about that process so you know
you're two women excited about gaming
and the opportunity for mobile games how
do you decide on egg baby as opposed to
you know the million other ideas that
you could have worked on yeah um I baby
so we both love tech games so that's the
beginning of it we both played neopets
and we all hide out tamagotchis
obviously and so just to clarify like
egg baby these are like big eyed eggs on
your phone that you interact with and
then depending on what you've been doing
with egg it will shape into different
personalities and then it will hatch
into different creatures that you
collect based on the personalities that
you've raised him into so egg baby we
looked at like that store and there was
just like hundreds of pet games out
there but none of them were good and we
think it's because the people who made
them don't really love pet games
themselves they were just like oh look
we should make a pact game because
there's probably a market out there for
people who love packings and so like if
you're coming from place of not really
true understanding you kind of have to
resort on stereotypes or like focus
groups and may or may not be accurately
run and we thought we could do better
got it so I guess what are some of the
you know the the key things about bad
games that you thought were missing at
the time and you know just I guess the
process by which you sorted through all
the ones on the app store yeah so it's
actually I can point out against a few
examples it's very hard though because
every single time you make a design
decision it matters but like something
like
the pet having every interaction have a
consequence we don't see a lot of that
in the app store that like freedom of
choice and like self-expression and that
creativity is a lot of things that are
actually missing games in general right
now and then just like the way that the
egg looks and like even that the art is
different it's it's like cuter more
appealing to young women alright I guess
I'm curious about your experience you
know as a dual female founding duo you
know what was the process of raising
venture capital like for example or you
know even pitching the concept of games
that appeal to women yes so as I said in
the beginning we had no experience and
we weren't we weren't like VPS of some
gaming company so we didn't have that
credibility we didn't know anyone in the
industry and so and we and we didn't
know how to code and so actually we
learned I know it was really bad we
didn't know anything and it was just two
of us right so you can as you can
imagine if you're going out to girls
with this and we're like okay we're
going to make it this game I'm going to
create a company catering to young women
but we don't have any experience we
don't have any skills it's very
difficult to get money so the first
thing we did was to learn well we did
two things what was meet as many people
as possible and the other thing was to
learn to code and so we both learned
like very very simple code off the
internet to make a very simple prototype
and I think the prototype was okay but
it was more like the seriousness of
purpose that got people to be like ok
they're not just you know like try to
get money and seeing what they can do
with it it's like they're really serious
about this and then met just as many
people as possible it was actually
really difficult and also I'm a South
African citizen and so like trying to
start a company in the US when you're
not a US citizen that was like another
hurdle but eventually after just like a
terrible time we we met as many people
as possible finally okay so the last
thing that happened was I couldn't be in
the US the border officials had said if
you try to come back anytime soon like
we're not going to let you and so I was
like okay but they're very vague about
it and at the time my savings were at
the bottom and
like we didn't have investors that were
signed on so I was like okay I got to go
home to South Africa for a little bit
with my parents which of course they
were very not happy with in their asian
so it's like it's really difficult and
then but after a month in South Africa
is like this is not going to go anywhere
there's it's not the love of gaming the
game industry it's not as big in South
Africa obviously as it is in us and one
other place which was China so I know
how to speak Mandarin which is very
lucky and like thank you to my parents
so I went to China where there's people
with money and people who are really
interested in gaming and I also
networked there I eventually found this
gaming founder he had like 500 employees
and was making 10 million dollars a
month on this game and he was like this
is obvious there's clearly an overlooked
market here for young women so he took a
chance on us and then Brandon Beck who's
the founder of riot games in los angeles
he had been a mentor before and so I had
to call him and be like look I can't
come see you aright now because I can't
come in to us but I'm raising this angel
wrap can you please give me money and
luckily he said yes and the other person
said yes and between the two of them
they worried enough credibility so that
the rest of the angel investors were
like okay the they're successful gaming
company founders and they saw some
things so they followed that was the
first round that's really tough I
imagine that um you know they're you
know given this the story it's a there's
a lot of panicking panicking panicking
and at some point you know you're at
this point wow this actually might work
you know what was that point for you oh
I remember at the time I wrote an email
to my boyfriend that was all caps that
was just like we have money but even
then like it was actually very uh cuz i
still had to get my visa sorted I was
worried about because money hadn't hit
the bank account yet we were still going
to draft the documents everybody just
verbally or committed on email whatever
and I was worried that they would pull
out if my visa couldn't work out and
there was a whole like scary time until
we got the money and I and I didn't
actually get the visa for like a year
after that but the year after that it
was much more settled and then the
second round of financing the VC
financing
that was after egg baby had launched so
we made it like when race angel
financing made egg baby egg baby took
off organically by itself so the bio
time we were raising VC financing we had
eight million downloads with no
marketing it was three people and it was
clearly taking off we were cash flow
positive and so that was like really
easy round it was night and day and so
you know 8 million downloads no
marketing that's a by all accounts a
miracle and a bloodbath that is a
today's App Store so how did you do it
you know what's it what's the magic
there ah you know it's funny because we
didn't we didn't do any marketing right
so but I my best guess it would have to
be I guess is that it resonated very
well with the most of teenage girls that
are playing it and because if you look
at the reviews they're all talking about
like I told my whole school I told my
friend my best friend told me about this
my entire family's playing this like
that kind of its they just they just
told each other so it must have been
something that they saw in there that
they couldn't finding other pet games
got it and so the you know the stats are
pretty overwhelming you know sixty
percent of teenage girls between 13 and
17 I believe play games why you know why
are companies ignoring this phenomenon
if they enjoy making money I think you
know you there are actually companies
now well there's more conversation
around women in tech and warming gaming
and there's more companies turning their
I to like the female market but gaming
is you know it comes from the heart
there's like a there's science I mean
there's like science and business meets
heart and the heart portion a lot of
people went into the gaming industry
because they love playing games
themselves and they may or may not be
interested or passionate about making a
particular type of game for a
demographic that's not themselves like
it's it's just the way that maybe some
people well I mean we were all raised
differently based on gender sometimes
and that that can skew your what you're
interested in right got it and so you
know as a gamer what were some of your
formative game experiences you know
either growing up or even you know
later on it I played a lot of simulation
games so I played sims and some city
were big i just do i think the broad
trend through what i was playing is that
i didn't play a lot of violent or
competitive games and so next hydra does
not make any violent or competitive
games cuz not that i don't like them
it's just or disapprove of them it's
just that like there's so many out there
that are already very good like why are
we going to that market and i do love
other types of games more I've obviously
played a lot of neopets like I said that
was for a few years and then actually
beyond gaming I mean it's also like the
way that you even when you were really
on or when I was really young playing
dolls and Barbies and like playsets and
that kind of the the kind of play that's
like exploring social identities and
social interactions that kind of plays
really interesting it's not very well
explored on mobile right now but we
could bring that to mobile as well got
it and so you know what about a mobile
gaming in particular do you define
interesting for women as opposed to
consoles pcs VR so really easy one
because everybody has one and so they're
constantly on the go I mean pc is like
there's a culture around pc gaming that
women are not really part of and but
like the mobile it's it's like you have
it on you and you can just if you're
waiting for something you could just
pick it up and play it right got it do
you see that you know DC that culture
changing in 10-15 years you know will
there be some convergence between you
know more traditional competitive
male-dominated design and I guess
cooperative mechanics that you're
looking to explore nurturing ones i hope
the gaming industry can be more diverse
and just that both women and men can
like play each other's games what like
just just a lot more variety of games
and people in that industry do I see it
converging yeah I think I so like as
people accept and make more games for
women yeah like the I think that is a
distinct possibility it so tell me a bit
more about the the culture of Nyx Hydra
and you
how you go about you know hiring people
who are passionate about games for women
as well as you know female gamers yeah
herons been tough because most of the
gaming industry are men and so not and
we don't it's not like we only hire a
woman's about sixty percent woman we
just look for people who are very
interested in our mission and are
passionate about what we do and like and
respect young women and that can be hard
sometimes it like one of those things
don't check off we look for people with
their three things we generally look for
its awareness so awareness of self and
others and the world and like it goes
deep into like mortality and that kind
of stuff up and then there's bravery and
teamwork rachelle self-explanatory and
then the the environment in general in
our products we try to make magical
colorful friendly products and so it's
like someone who's interested in that
kind of things it helps if you like cute
things because when most of all things
lean cute even though they'll have like
a little bit of Darkness or a little bit
of bite but there's always cute got it
so you know what most people talk about
mobile gaming broadly they split it into
you know casual mid-core and and core
right and you know for for one reason or
another casual tends to conflate with
games that are predominantly targeted
towards female gamers from a
philosophical standpoint how do you how
do you think of nyx Hydra versus a
company called Activision which you know
also has a sixty percent audience and
you know candy crush and and so forth
she has plenty of Activision is now the
candy crush person but yeah the casual
thing you know my marketing person is
actually doing a panel on a casual
connect about what is casual it we feel
like sometimes it's used not maliciously
just just like everyone's used to using
it as like a game that's friendly to
women and so it can be offensive
sometimes I mean because a lot of all
games are very immersive and so that's
another way that you might want to
define hardcore games just like a world
that you can get immersing for a long
time and it has a lot of complexity so
that's to the car and then what sorry I
missed the second question I guess you
know you know
let's say you know there's a group of
people i King working on their new
puzzle master game or some variant of a
puzzle game predominantly targeted
towards a female audience you know I
assume there's some overlap in the sense
that you're both looking to reach the
same group of people but there must be
some difference in terms of you know the
experiences you're prioritizing what
you're looking to deliver to your your
customers yeah I actually think the
reason that they were so successful is
because appeal to so many women they
they were around for a long time and I
think they found what works for them and
I'm not sure that they got a well I
can't speak for them but like it's it's
because it took a long time to get them
to where they found a hit that was a hit
was mostly women right and so it's going
to be very hard to go away from that
model and try to exploring new kinds of
game genres whereas we do have a little
more flexibility and like not just match
three games we're not making a match 3
game but like we could look at other
types of game genres that are not really
or game types that are not well explored
right now and do those and so you know
what uh what other game types do you
think are you know ripe for the taking
and the the market for women gamers okay
so uh but that's only you were doing
next so more narrative and social
interactions but not not necessarily it
doesn't even have to be like a real
person to person social but something so
like I refer to earlier about like
playing with dolls that kind of or
playing house that kind of mechanic or
likes exploration of like disposable
identities like your self identity a lot
more like self-expression type of games
a lot more co-op games not to kill other
people like just just literally like
collaborative games that are and it also
like the type of it could be the same
type of game but just treat it
differently so like a lot of like a
match 3 game could be competitive but it
doesn't have to be there could be other
ways to express that type of game so
operating a
live game is a fairly challenging
process you know you have this audience
that loves your product they've invested
so much of their time sometimes their
money and you know their personal kind
of their soul to some extent and to your
product you know what are some of the I
guess greatest challenges you've had an
operating egg baby and some of the
things that you've learned as a result
yeah we had a lot of challenges
operating a baby because when we
launched there was three people and we
were not ready for the onslaught of fans
and like you know where we launched it
wasn't even a launch it was we were
supposed to be dropped it to tested we
were supposed to just get like you know
like 10 to 50 people who picked it up
and just told us how many you have to
balance the game so it's like how many
coins did you get for feeding the egg
that kind of thing so we didn't put a
lot of features that were supposed to
being it was an incomplete game when it
went out and so does a lot of like
catching up with features with three
people trying to hire more people at the
same time one of the I mean most
embarrassing things we let like I think
it was four months go by without an
update because it was just such a big
update and a lot was a lot of features
and we couldn't get it out in time
because there wasn't enough people so
that was definitely a challenge and then
like obviously every time you wait for
updates to go out the the active numbers
will plummet and then we'll go back up a
little bit as you get but you lose
people as you obviously if you don't
update for 44 months that's really bad
so you know for the next game that we're
doing we have a lot more people now we
have 34 people so but we're ready with
like we know what's going to be the game
that's coming out is complete more or
less way more than egg baby ever was and
then like we have the update schedules
and everything's setting there's more
infrastructure like that's the other
thing we didn't have a lot of
infrastructure in terms of game
development and so there's more
infrastructure to like deliver those
updates as quickly as possible so we're
going to do as fast as two weeks
sometimes four-week updates so there's a
pretty wide perception that uh you know
I think in the public markets and even
in private markets that gaming is just a
hit driven business you know just can't
tell something's going to work or not
and you just repeat this cycle and rinse
and repeat so you know how how are you I
guess
transcending that you know how are you
moving beyond egg baby to kind of mix
Hydra as an enduring company yeah so we
talk we get asked that question a decent
amount and the thing with hip based
businesses is that usually it's very
crowded and so that's why it's hippest
there's just so many people coming from
the same angle in the same perspective
that it can be hard to stand out but if
you find an area where people aren't
really looking very hard it's a lot
easier to make a hit not that some luck
isn't involved as well because there are
so many factors going on in the world at
any point right that like that could
lead to something but generally if you
try to fit find a less sparse space so
like I was saying earlier some game
genres that are not well explored that
people are waiting for you have a better
chance and so you know egg baby managed
to grow organically you know how are you
thinking about community management or
you know trying to repeat that success
with some of your future titles we have
not been very good with community
management and that's something that I
got to work on as well luckily OCH unity
is very nice unlike a lot of other
gaming communities I mean what one time
like if this happened to another gaming
company it would be so like they'll be
getting death threats but one time on
Android we actually had a bug go out
that like lost everybody's data and to
like you know like you're hatching like
you had your like 50 creatures and
they're like well they're all gone and
people would write and be like hey I
love this game like I'm sorry to bother
you but all my creatures are gone you
know like I understand you guys must be
so busy and like it must be a hard time
for you guys and we're like oh my god
you're so cute and of course like we try
to make it up as much as possible but
yeah so like if it was another a lot of
other gaming communities would not be
doing that right they'd be like he
better die that kind of
so yeah that's it's a nice segue
actually into another gaming community
so for those of you that don't know
there's this a survival game called rust
that recently made a change to randomize
race and gender to every character in
the game and on top of that they found
that to your account so you can never
change that it's been a lot of backlash
I'm just curious about you know given
the you know what we're talking about
you know in terms of including you know
gamers of different genders you know
maybe different races as well you know
what are your thoughts on on that change
and you know how it speaks to you know
the commute the potential gaming
community is going forward so we try to
there's one thing that we try to avoid
which is teaching people something like
it and I don't mean we're okay with
accidentally teaching people something
but actively trying to teach people
something can be sometimes people will
be all put off by that and it's always
like a can be a condescending if you
don't do it right so what like gaming
it's one of those one of the joys of
gaming is that what's in the game is
fair usually like you have the rules are
fair whereas in life the rules are not
fair and so with that one we we try to
give like hope for a magical colorful
friendly world right so it's it would be
better for us like if we were going to
make that game you would be able to
choose because it kind of sucks being
allocated certain like I understand
they're trying to promote empathy but we
wouldn't try to we would more give an
example of empathy and like try to lead
by example of what's colorful magical
friendly vs pushing that on somebody and
forcing them like you better have
empathy now because you are now not the
race that's privileged or whatever it's
it's a different approach that we would
take so so seems like mobile has been a
great platform for you
deliver gaming experiences the women you
know just based on the ubiquity of that
platform and everyone's lives you know
what do you think uh you know pc games
for women might look like VR games you
know how does that change on a platform
by platform basis we going to try to go
forward so like more new platforms and
something like pc or console unless one
of all mobile games happens to port
really easily to pc they won't do that
for VR i mean i played around with a lot
of year sense that my favorite would be
the cardboard one because it's easier
and lighter but i haven't found one i'm
waiting for one that is very friendly to
women and it's not i mean like something
as basic as like it messes up your hair
and makeup like that's a consideration
that people may not be thinking of when
they're designing it but if there's
something light and chic that you can
wear it yeah like well look into that
area i'm kind of i'm also interested in
wearable week especially like that
fashionable looking variables that could
be fun so mixed high driving is a gaming
company right now and will continue to
make games but there's other areas are
fun on tech that we'd be interested in
exploring as well got it and you know as
a as a founder how are you how do you
manage that timing and you know the the
resources of the company and decide you
know when a step like that makes sense
as soon as i see it as soon as I see a
platform that I feel like either a lot
of young women are going to go onto your
that they're already the growth is there
will start planning for what to do with
that platform so so what advice would
you give to you know some passionate
female gamer is looking to start a
company targeting with women today well
there's two choices they could work they
could work on their own thing right
start their own company in which case
the advice would be perseverance just
don't give up keep going and then of
other choices if you feel like you just
want to make a game versus create an
entire comp
then you should come talk to me
obviously we're constantly looking we're
really looking for people that make
awesome content for young women it's
just we couldn't find a lot so we had to
make our own and will continue to make
home but I'm constantly on the lookout
for people who make that kind of stuff
and we can maybe help publish or help
with their marketing since we do have a
lot of fans now that kind of thing and I
guess you know how do you see that
structurally shifting you know clearly
there's this level of interest but how
do we get more women involved in the
game industry you know over a 10 to 20
year you know right the first thing we
want to do is just make the environment
in the industry very friendly so a lot
of conferences parties like this year at
GDC the game developer conference for
example I don't know how many of you
heard like at the microsoft party they
just they hired a lot of like go-go
dancers so that kind of thing is not
very friendly to women so like we're
moving that kind of thing and then just
add conferences you know it's just like
considering is friendly or just having
more women on on the Planning Committee
for instance here or have they act the
decisive power to be like okay this is
what I want to do and once the
environments friendly I think people who
are women who are naturally interested
will go more that way one thing that
some people try to do is like try to
push women into a particular area to be
like go more into tech go more into
gaming and it's like it can be difficult
time saying are you saying where men are
at is better than what women are at
right now you know is it depending on
that angle that your protein it could be
not that productive but like if you make
the environment friendly show them how
fun it is and how pleasant it is to
being there then they'll come I mean are
you seeing any commonalities and you
know how some of the I guess your
current employees have you know found
your company and got inspired to join
what I guess like are they passionate
players of egg baby that you know
I love this game you know I want to join
a company or you know are you
discovering them from other communities
or I guess any commonalities in
background yeah it's a lot of people who
don't feel like they are welcome or
fitting tiling other companies what kind
of like a sanctuary for people who maybe
don't like the corporate talk siddity
like corporate environments or people
who have experienced some kind of like
in like very male-dominated companies
maybe they experience something negative
and still like they're very it's like an
island of happiness for them that would
be like the one common alley yeah well
how do you how do you keep your how do
you keep your team happy you know how is
the culture evolved over time yeah I
think about that a lot um and I'm
constant well so like one of the things
we'll do is heart-to-hearts some people
call them 110 ones but we call them
heart-to-hearts which is a kind of
cheesy but it works so like one month
after you join we have a heart-to-heart
to be and it's feedback from your
manager to you but you you to the
manager as well and just knowing that
you can say anything in that space and
it's not going to be held like against
you and then like we'll do it every
three months just to do a checking that
they are happy but aside from that the
environment I mean so we have a four day
workweek for instance we have it's 10
hours per day and then tuesday to friday
so living la you don't have to drive as
much which is really helpful and then
you get your three-day weekend where
they're refresh and they come back more
productive people really like that we're
dog friendly we have like eight dogs in
the office constantly you can like where
we have 10 ends days which is like the
first wednesday of every month you can
walk around in onesies I mean honestly
you can walk around once these any time
but like that's the day that we
celebrate the craziness it's just like
making the environment and the most
important thing is like hiring people
who are friendly and team-oriented right
some people they coming and there might
be superstars but they have a lot of bit
of that climber mentality or like mmm
the corporate like toxicity and then we
can't let them make because they would
ruin the environment what're I guess
some of the you know I most important
changes in a company culture structure
that you've gotten through you know the
heart to hearts or any of the feedback
mechanisms that you have you know this
is actually embarrassing because there
are two things that have been brought up
and they have not been changed because
it's so difficult communication between
people so a lot of people are sitting at
their desk skyping with people instead
of walking over to the desks and be like
that's that's something we try very like
we were figuring out right now how to
get people because we have a key we have
a lot of introverts is one of the things
so there's two problem yeah introverts
and then people who might be they don't
want to hurt someone's feelings for
instance if they want to speak up in a
meeting and so like that kind of thing
has been brought up in many hearts ours
and we're working on right now so that's
one and then the other one is more
physical activity so we're looking to
like maybe like a yoga class once a
month or something like that and then
one time which what we tried to do a
like four o'clock would go for a group
walk around the block but it's a cut
take so and it may sounds like you know
a lot of kind of a lot of what you've
done so far works for for the team and
it's a closely knit group you know how
do you how do you think of making that
transition you know let's say from 30
people to 300 people and maybe 3,000
like you know what what needs to change
and how are you going to scale
I'm going to have to get a lot of advice
on that before we you know start ramping
up like that I did do this cool thing
where I got to shadow another CEO who
had about 120 people and I just
shattered followed her around for the
whole day just to see what she does and
her company is very happy as well and I
was very encouraged by the fact that you
can go over 100 people and still have
like really happy relaxed and like cool
people in your company and the culture
can be really cool set I'm definitely
going to learn from that and talk to her
more and find other people who have
similar situations when I get there got
it and uh yeah I guess you know any any
other games besides a egg baby that you
find particularly inspiring today or
just thought provoking what are people
in the office playing look so people in
the office right now or playing me tomo
obviously because it's Nintendo's first
thing that came out and so a lot of
people are trying it out i don't know
how long were going to stay on it but
the one that I found impressive it's not
really I guess inspiring the level of
Polish that they did it's called carrot
fantasy and it so it used to be called
patek carrot actually we found it
through one of our programmers
girlfriends and like it just like swept
through you know Naomi my co-founder me
and like other people in the office it's
actually just a very simple tower
defense but where you have to protect a
very cute carrot so all the monsters are
really cute the character like the
characters are really cute but the level
of Polish that's gone to making sure
that the game is fun on every single
level is pretty amazing and so that we
got really addicted to yeah and I guess
with that am I Nino is publishing kind
of given the audience that the size of
the audience that you built and
looking to build something of interest
to you or definitely harder yes we would
love to not have to make all the games
for girls ourselves yes it's with that
mining it looked open the up to some Q&A
my god hi great the discussions highly
listen that's right testing so with that
it's awesome all be as soon as you've
had you know building up a baby and
lodging other things with la being a
center of content would you think about
creating and a web videos with two
characters because two characters and
your bird store does it as a game and
now it's a movie it's a franchise its
licensing there's all these clothing so
you know being sold so with a baby since
you have such cute characters it seems
like a pretty cool segue especially with
you know I'm sure like tons of your only
friends and my other friends could help
with that yeah there is a reason why la
that's one of them yes we are interested
and I hope we have actually been
approached but the team is not big
enough right now that we can devote time
to like a movie and more games but that
is something that we're interested in
and will like as soon as we get the game
process smoothly lockdown then we'll
look into the other extensions we have
merch coming out now so that's the first
expansion of the IP but yeah we do free
to play because it's more accessible
that's part of being the friendly part
of the magical colorful friendly and
then we test is the other to get the
monetization right there's like giant
expel cell excel sheets based on like
data that we're getting as to how to
tune the pricing or something so which
one
you're picking or am i okay hi so what
did you was there anything you took away
from your Yale experience that's helped
you on this entire journey the people is
actually here so my co-founders ala I
met two of my leading investors through
yay lease but it was like four steps to
remove it was like yay Lee other person
or the person as a person eventually the
investor but yeah they started with
Yalie so like the people really matters
and the coal community generally when
you made a lemon I they're really ready
to help when they're really friendly
that's been very helpful as well oh look
lena long term where do you where do you
see this going you know sell your
company a go IPO let's hope book an IPO
but it will take a while I would love to
build a large company of many small
pause that make cool and fun products
for young women that's based on some
layer of tech because usually when you
tech product comes out the like it
people aren't thinking about young woman
is the first thing that they want to
make things for and so we want to be
that company thank you I'm Lena Tyler
thank you for hosting this panel I'm
curious Lena in the past few years
there's been a lot of news reports about
bullying and trolling of female gamers
in the industry and just last year this
year actually like a south by conference
was even cancelled curious what your
thoughts are about this solutions going
forward or even just war stories that
you've experienced or you've heard about
yeah that's kind of the toxicity that I
that's part of the toxicity that I was
talking about were like all companies a
little bit of island a lot of the stuff
that we make
consider it sounds weird but not really
considered real games by the hardcore
male gamers and so they kind of leave us
alone because they're like well it's
irrelevant and they just ignore us and
so we leave luckily we haven't
personally been targeted like that but
it's obviously unacceptable to target
anyone like that based on um it's just
like their gender obviously I brandon
has a question hey so great work I've
worked in the games business most of my
PO co career so what you've said is
really resonated with me and I often
wonder why a bunch of dudes don't target
young girls in a non-creepy way I was a
joke right I'm sorry and that's why so
um another good job and and like I think
it's really there's a huge opportunity
i'm curious one thing from an
entrepreneurial standpoint how do you
set the vision and the priorities and
the allocation of scarce resources with
a co-founder and and then the second
level question if you let me ask is how
do you think about your target audience
because you've gone pretty young girl
which I would argue is very different
from mature woman gaming as a target
audience and so if you could talk a
little bit about both of those things oh
well I've known only for over ten years
now so it helps to know the other person
really low and their values and what
they wanted but you want to have a
conversation about where you want the
company to go and then obviously each
product these towards that show and then
you have a clear like who decides what
so she's the chief creative officer soon
which means like if it comes down to
like the art style this versus that like
she will have that call versus i'll have
like a business-related call something
and then the second part about older
versus younger women also egg baby we
mated a kind of foil cells but it ended
up being like teenage girls and some
tweens and then we're going to depending
on the game the next game is going to
h up a little bit so like late teens
early 20s and then the game after that
is really targeted for women in their
20s because that's sort of like we can
understand about as much as like how old
we are and younger it's kind of hard to
like look forward into all futures
elliot from McLarty associates has a
question he flew here from DC for the
conference hell yeah thanks very much um
I read that you're from South Africa my
family's also South Africa I from
Queenstown that's what I is London
that's really close interesting how does
that point does it play into any of what
you're doing now do you see it playing
into you know any future strategies
global growth the state of girls and
women in in Africa in sub-saharan Africa
and South Africa in particular Thanks I
think it's more than approach so because
I grew up well so I was you know I moved
around a lot and that perspective that
global perspective helps and just help
sting hiring people to have you know you
put you appreciate the value of
different perspectives and diverse
anymore when you grow up in various
countries what was it was there a second
part
you know I actually I feel like I grew
up a lot of American IPS and then most
of our company are most like they
understand American culture the best so
that's where else trans is like if we
had to try to make a game for example I
really do want the egg franchise to go
to China and Japan but we're going to
need partners because we don't
understand you know what they love and
so we might misinterpret it and so we've
got to beat we got to go start with
where else trenzas and then see where we
can expand Sophia who is a games market
or herself as a yeah I just wanted to
say that the number of users you've been
able to acquire without any marketing
has been really really impressive and
you know congratulations I work in
marketing in mobile games myself and so
I'm just kind of curious you know now
that you do have a marketing function
within the company what the strategy has
given your unique position of how many
organic users you've been able to
acquire yeah it's a it's a huge
challenge so we have a whole like
there's many levers in a marketing plan
for the upcoming game and what I can say
about is that I think it will get has a
ton of users in the first week but I
don't know because I've never done it
before inter I actually there's one part
of the strategy that I can maybe talk
about you off offline but it's allowed
to say it's not what people usually do
to acquire mobile users and it's very
specifically targeted towards young
women don't you stand up hey how's it
going macking I work for Microsoft and
I'm really glad that you mentioned the
GDC event so there's been a lot of
discussion inside Microsoft I work in
sales which is it primarily male
dominant Microsoft is 70 / seventy-six
percent white and roughly about asthma
seventy-six percent mail and I think
about sixty seventy percent white and
then my personal through my mom
partner it keeps him down the cruncher
back when there were very few female
partners there so being a woman in the
gaming industry and looking at kind of
the the dominant tone the male dominance
in that what are some things that gaming
companies and the large corporates like
Microsoft could do to be more proactive
engaging companies like yourself like
Nick's Hydra and then just kind of
pushing the envelope and thinking about
how do you dress this market and that
how his companies can we be more
inclusive we could maybe co-host events
do you mean in terms of like I mean just
like more conversations obviously it
helps to more understanding I'm not she
not sure how about hire smart woman
anyway no I think yeah that's a good
point yeah um but yeah I mean do do any
large corporations reach out to you
because what you're doing or has anybody
tried to start a dialogue around 10 is
10 cent doing anything on trying to
engage in not too much but there are
certain companies that are more
interested in talking to us because of
our particular angle but it's not it's
never like a question of hey how can we
make I'll company more women friendly I
don't remember getting that question
yeah it's more like they want to keep
tabs on us in case we conquer the market
and thank you I think I know you're
getting a visit and film when there was
not some woman and film the Geena Davis
or Institute where she actually does
consulting with movie studios to make
sure that they the movie scripts and the
movie steward themselves are more female
friendly and have more female lead
characters so maybe the question is you
know there could be a consulting
division that actually helps other
companies be more you know mindful any
other questions oh yeah also so my name
is Davis if you know which may have two
short questions first
sunda culture why tuesday to friday vs
monday through thursday who drove that
and second question on your users what
did you learn that you didn't know when
you create the first game that you're
incorporating on the second game if
you're free to share okay so the first
one is really easy which is mondays that
usually like the butt of jokes it's so
bad I like to go back on a Monday so
well I guess not everyone else goes back
to on Monday but you get to do whatever
you want it it's like it's like a nice
so that's one one and then the other
question hmm that we learned well one of
the biggest things that it was more it
we learned it and we were going to go in
that direction anyway I guess but it's
even more sure now is that that
demographic is very viral and so if you
make a good product for them you have
that organic lift hopefully and so it
made us more certain that that's the
correct demographic to target the level
of conversation that they have like them
just posting eggs on Instagram without
us even having like the screenshot
function or sharing or anything like
that with surprising other questions
have one I've ever partnered with
influencers as a lot of teen influencers
or it's not so you don't need to because
you already have great word of mouth
maybe don't need that yeah we've never
partnered with influencers but it's not
out of the question yes about five more
minutes
would you think about expand into other
countries or expose your team as far as
a team well as far as the game and the
marketing for the game definitely China
and Japan and then I see yes we'll have
to get like one or two people there on
the ground probably but most of the team
will be in the United States still
attract how international your game is
like how many downloads of yours
countries like South Africa or Europe
Asia it's mostly english-speaking
countries very heavily in the US Canada
UK that kind of thing but also because
for egg baby we only translated to three
other languages so Spanish German
Portuguese and that's because we saw
that it was there was a lot of organic
players in Brazil which was like
Brazilian Portuguese and then Germany
and the Spanish just because we thought
it would hit more countries but for the
next game we're translating to 10 more
countries that will be interesting to
see what that does hi I want to know how
many egg babies you've made yourself I
you know it's actually very sad because
I don't get to play the game as a normal
person and like I have to constantly
like delete the app and then get the
latest build and play that so I've
actually probably killed more egg babies
and left them to die that I have like
actually hatched them like yeah curious
but a given how focused you are on the
female audience how many males are in
your employee base and also your male
employees are they at a disadvantage
because you know they may not have a
full understanding of your
some kind of games you develop well when
we hire them we want to screen them so
that they are like understanding
respectful and like this so they've
already passed the test right and at
that point there there was in the family
like it's we try to be inclusive you
know and so part of the when a cake
companies very male-dominated it can
sometimes be not inclusive and that's
something that we don't want to become
if we're very female oriented we don't
become not inclusive two men right
percentage-wise about fourteen percent i
would actually it'd be cool it was more
because i feel like if more men can feel
comfortable playing games that are what
what society considers feminine the
world would actually be a better place
so I probably wasn't listening closely
enough but you've done one or two rounds
of financing to Angel VC okay and how
many how many of the VCS were females as
opposed to men or was it a firm that had
any females and did you have any trouble
dealing with male investors so none of
our investor czar females all male but
they're all very cool dudes who are
chill and understanding obviously the
the fee sea foam it's actually you know
suits four of them white guys and they
looked at themselves and they were like
were four white dudes what are we
missing because we're four white dudes
and that question is what is like oh you
have great awareness and perspective and
that's good enough I mean you can't
decide like what gender and race you
were born as right so like as long as
you have awareness of others and
yourself that's good enough we could we
didn't it's not that we didn't accept
obviously wasn't that weird indexed a
female found
investors which is couldn't find a lot
of them especially I mean in a beginning
the angel round yet most most angel
investors are men sometimes it was hard
because when in the angel investment
portion they kind of invest because
they're personally interested or
passionate about something but if you're
like we're gonna make games for a young
woman they might not be as interested in
personally so it could be a little
harder to raise that round katherine
from IBM has a question yeah we don't
have wednesday wednesday at IBM and
please don't even tell me what a onesie
is i don't know because i make my job
and come down and work for you guys so i
recently read an article about this cat
collecting game neko atsume and york
times yeah i know a lot about that
community it's really not important why
but um so I was interested that it was
in the New York Times which is making it
like not you know organic social or
anything like that and then there was an
article you know we could go or to that
my son cut out my door saying mom read
this about Minecraft and i thought i was
listening to you talk about like how
your games are different and they appeal
a different audience just because of
what they are and how this different
audience thinks and works I'm wondering
if anybody's approached you from
journalism or academia to explore those
ideas like its your game actually
shaping a new way of thinking and
interacting online we've actually we've
gone more press lately I think that
we've been mostly ignored by most people
I think it's like because we're not
fully we don't fit into the mold of like
a typical gaming company and then people
who are writing about games generally it
might not be as interested but I think
there's more interest now because
there's more conversation about
different types of games and diversity
that cat game though that caffeine is
really interesting because it actually
plays off like it awards you for not
coming back into the game it's just like
negative space gaming which is like
really no one else has done it in that
way so that's pretty cool thanks for
spending the time with this Lena and
relaxation